Sentinel corporation security services
or Sentinel Corps is a private military
company who are hired by JCL after the
bombing of scale foundation head office
their main job on Aurora to keep it safe
and secure from potential inside and
outside threats however not long after
Col Dee Walker came onto the island to
act as scales military adviser the
Sentinels along with walkers wolves
joined forces turned their back on scale
tech and rapidly took control of the
islands
[Music]
[Music]
Sentinel takes over arrows main
datacenter and cuts access to the web by
severing the ocean bottom cables and
then took charge of all centers with
satellite communication they then seize
control of burrowers only airport tower
while other agents simultaneously locked
down the harbormaster's office cutting
off all communications with
international sea traffic and
effectively trapping everyone on the
archipelago within an hour of the
operation signal jamming drones swarm
the skies and Ayana piri broadcasts an
alert on all the raw electronic devices
she informs the populace of Jay scales
abduction and urges them to comply with
the Sentinel call she acquires complete
control of scale tick three hours after
the takeover all defense and
surveillance measures are now fully
active the sea around Aurora is heavily
monitored including anti-aircraft
missile batteries and legion twin septa
drones which had deployed all over the
islands the ship USNS CA is destroyed by
legion drones as it attempts to leave
the area
carrying sensitive information in
response to the ship sinking the US Navy
establishes a surveillance zone around
the raw long-range reconnaissance
aircraft monitor the area alongside a
nuclear submarine
a cruiser and two destroyers are put on
standby 200 nautical miles after our on
the CIA's recommendation international
naval and air authorities prohibit ships
and planes from approaching within 300
nautical miles several teams of ghosts
are dispatched or are in operation
greenstone commences originally Skell
hired Sentinel under its government
contacts recommendation this contact was
CIA deputy director of operations Peter
miles what scale wasn't aware of was
miles long standing relationship with
Sentinel CEO Trey stone and Col Dee
Walker as part of the rep team
Walker and stone ran illegal black op
missions for the CIA and a Mars
leadership the Wolfson Sentinel are
essentially working for the same party
while Sentinel highly-trained PMC's and
walkers Wolf's a bunch of ex ghosts the
wolves are treated much more like super
soldiers which means the Sentinel troops
are more often tasks of the more mundane
jobs such as going out on patrols or
monitoring the barren areas of the
desert or swamps because of this even
though they basically work for the same
people there is still a certain amount
of friction between the groups
not long after skeltox headquarters
honor oil was bombed Sentinel Corps
issued martial law local inhabitants are
now required to follow a series of rules
or radicals while under martial law
population without any task must stay in
their residence or city population with
tasks delivered by Sentinel Corps must
accomplish this task it's forbidden to
travel in the wild all people discover
in the wild a central core patrol will
be arrested
if you need to travel to accomplish your
task Sentinel vehicles will carry you to
your workplace help them to identify or
capture an outcast is rewarded by 50000
scale credits helping to find Jace Cal
is rewarded by 1 million any people
helping the outcasts will be arrested
and punished Sentinel core members can
freely fire weapons and residences and
cities to fight the outcasts all
communications with the wrister world
apart during the martial law all travel
outside of the archipelago is forbidden
unfortunately Sentinel often abuses
their power of the population of Aurora
and can often be seen executing a number
of workers and other innocent people at
scale outposts born and raised in a
suburb outside of Memphis Tennessee
Stone comes from an old Southern family
who raised him as a Southern gentleman
although as a child he was considered a
bit wild the structure and discipline of
the military school helped him focus his
energy and ambitions he is a true
patriot and his patriotism will always
include a special place in his heart for
a southern heritage stone graduated from
Virginia Military Institute with a
degree in civil engineering but his
first commission was as a psyops officer
after working with him on several
occasions the ghost recruited stone and
he joined his highly secretive unit
named the retaliation team or Red Team
while in the red team stone was running
illegal black ops missions for the CIA
alongside men like Col Dee Walker who
was his platoon leader stone rose to the
rank of major but after 10 years decided
not to renew his contract opting instead
to go private
after a short time working with a number
of private military corporations stone
warmed his own private military company
Signal Corps he secured an abandoned
Russian military camp in Kazakhstan and
used to train as elite soldiers through
Peter miles stone was contracted to run
all security honor are fond of southern
euphemisms intelligent and sophisticated
stone was the kind of man who would
smile and shake your hand while
flaunting the knife he'd used to stab
you in the back never one to shy away
from an opportunity to further his own
agenda beneath the surface of the
southern politeness
sona's known to be very dangerous he is
a strong appetite for authority and an
equally strong fondness for destruction
he lacks empathy and he leans heavily
towards domination those under his
command know better than to ever
question him and his superiors thank God
every day that he was on the aside while
stone works directly with Walker the
answers to Peter miles his several
officers he relies upon Ilsa Hertzog the
sadistic prison warden Ian Blake the
manipulative head of the island secret
police and several others who have been
dispatched around the archipelago to
take care of those resisting Sentinel
Corps after Walker is killed by Nomad
stone in a phone call with miles remarks
that he is now in charge of Aurora and
that miles and his boss don't need to be
worried
the youngest of five children born to
Johannesburg socialites Elsa was always
distant to be the unheard voice her
older siblings were identified from an
early age as being exceptional beings in
a variety of fields
thus living young Elsa to defend for
herself small in stature and slow to
developed in the rest of her family she
retreated inward to a world of books and
fantasy over all she felt ignored and
nobody a silent observer in the
background and so because of this she
began to develop an uncanny ability to
read people in the behaviour and
therefore she began to imagine a career
in psychology and university her ideas
were solidified in her desire to
understand the human condition grew
still but a series of poor investments
by a father lifts the family broke
outcast and clouded in scandal Elsa was
forced to join the military to earn
money to continue her studies it was
during her time serving as an
intelligence analyst in the military
that his skills at manipulation
information extraction was first noticed
while assigned to the Defense
Intelligence Division of the South
African National Defence Force ulcer
identified herself as an exceptionally
talented interrogator she quickly
warranted prestige from superiors her
ability to break down even the toughest
prisoners however over time who methods
became more erratic and more savage and
eventually a series of investigations
forced her out of the military the
detail behind her termination of
employment was concealed by a supervisor
who felt she had a natural gift and she
was offered a position at the famed
Yvonne weyni
Correctional Center where she continued
to hone her craft it was during her
stint as the chief interrogator that she
first crossed paths with Col D Walker
who was conducting a joint training
exercise and detainee operations with
the Rickey's South Africa's premier
special operations unit following on
from the first meeting Walker often
called upon her expertise in
interrogation
while on red team missions
many citizens of Iraq could tell you
about Ilsa she is greatly feared
throughout the island her cruelty is
legendary
it is said that anyone sent to her does
not return Ilona who usually tries to
keep to herself Elsa has developed a
connection with rosebud one of Walker's
alpha Wolf's I guess you could even go
as far to say they're friends she is
loyal to fellow Sentinel Ian Blake and
believes wholly in the vision of world
2.0 they also began torturing scaled
technology employees in order to keep
them in line and sickeningly just to see
where their break points were she
swiftly traumatized several workers to
the point where one of them allied with
nomads in order to kill her after Nomad
freed several of Elsa's prisoners she
began to hunt them down eventually with
the aid of an attack helicopter she
managed to corner the ghost and a former
prisoners but shortly after the battle
ensued she was killed by nomads
in Blake is a disgraced former police
commissioner born and raised in Boston
prominent Irish American parents he was
always distant to wear a police badge
like his father before him and the four
previous generations of black men never
able to quite grasp his own moral code
he regularly found himself abusing his
position of power as a police officer to
further his own personal agenda his
excessive self absorption and the bitter
rivalry between homeowners abusive
father left and overly susceptible to a
multiple of influences he successfully
made a name for himself early on in his
career by racking up a series of big
arrests in relation to organized crime
and drug traits within Boston his
considerable network of informants and
snitches helped to accelerate his career
quickly through the ranks of the police
department and a true black form he
almost never played fair he often used
his position of power to plant evidence
for civilians to work as informants and
routinely abuse suspects in order to
extract information after the death of
two teenage boys who turned a notorious
drug dealer a case was launched against
Blake however due to his record of
high-profile arrests he was untouchable
and the case was dropped interestingly
the deal of the boys had helped to get
arrested mysteriously died while in
police custody
at 42 Blake was elected to the position
of police commissioner after the former
in command died in a car accident he
would be the youngest in Boston PD
history unfortunately for Blake he would
never escape his past in 2016 he was the
subject of an internal affairs
investigation and to allege corruption
within the department and a number of
former informants came forward to
testify while no criminal charges were
brought against him he was forced to
retire in disgrace eventually he started
his own business selling high-end
surveillance equipment and it was there
that Trey stone first approached him to
work for Sentinel as the chief
intelligence officer they've worked
closely together ever since
Blake stone remained Assizes himself as
a tough old street cop with refined
tastes
expensive soups and top-shelf whiskey
errors for max as as his fixation with
Heinrich Mueller chief of Gestapo in
Nazi Germany among others he's known for
his vicious temper and is quick to point
the finger on anyone but himself
Blake will happily destroy another
person's credibility and sabotage their
career just for shits and giggles
he truly relishes and bringing those
around him to the nice an incredibly
paranoid individual this is Victor that
he keeps intelligence files on everyone
on the island including stone and other
procedural executives because of his
disposition people really ever trust
Blake and therefore does not cultivate
many friendships it's rumored that he
has control of an AI system created by
scale tech that controls all the
surveillance drones simultaneously
creating an inescapable security network
within Blake assigned as sentinels chief
of surveillance well honor Allah he
superintended over the people and his
own troops with an iron fist frequently
he arrested and even sometimes killed
those civilians he deemed to be threats
Blake was also known to severely punish
and abuse Sentinel soldiers over the
most Manute of technical errors
no matter ventually hunts down blake to
acquire his bio signature and to shut
down the drone surveillance program
while dragging them into the control
center blake is mortally wounded by
alpha wolf silverback who's trying to
prevent nomads from succeeding and
shutting down the drone program nomads
succeeded in his mission but is unable
to catch silverback who managed to
escape he leaves blake behind to die
from his wounds with walker and a number
of the sentinel officers having been
taken out by the ghosts who would appear
that the military hold on the island is
well on its way to being broken but with
Trey stone alive and Peter miles still
calling the shots from the other side of
the planet this is far from over
although I have a couple of other groups
to cover like the outcasts and the
homesteaders what else would you like to
see me cover in break point before I
start getting into the ongoing storyline
that has been drip-feed to us through
the faction missions let me know in the
comments otherwise think uh very much
for watching and i'll catch you in the
next one Cheers
[Music]